інформатику результати представлені
рідних міністра іванна каверни до того
що диму і натиснули модератора сьогодні
тому що ви на під'їзді цей наш
модератор наталі сара жіночого на нас
правді за пропливала нам у мережі форми
роботи онлайн
екімова пустувала у всіх предметах так
то у нас клала нам таблиці та у нас клала
нам зіниці документі вікі дозволив і
звернув його ти дуже вив річки про псих
інформації в тому числі і кілька сну та
яви сну їх реалізувати і ми так само
вудлищем і форми роботи продовжилися і
надимського програма ви ще дуже важливо
птахи плаття тафта глибокого але за
галон кун від 70 пропозицій сам євро
howo але у цих змій на хікі будуть
дорослими і це маяки за броні на
приклад тема умовно основні склади та
комп'ютерів же казав і полів ще сухих
предметі у всіх програмах буде
забрано розсудив погоди нах так ось на
всю тему основні склади та комп'ютери
було в програмі бородача на 3 глодяни
іншому класі історія серед хворих
при старих було забрано комп'ютерну
петренко ви в чині начальник предметів
була забрана на порівнювали було про
формулювання ким чен нам я скажу без
ніша була за брані м і файли до папки
вік треба прибирати її на 2 до нас і
був разом броні складні так терміни та
заміни не наприклад чому з іншого
класі вже діти малі знат та терміни по
виду мене виду масті данії в сад і
заміни але на інформація заміна але
інформативніші процеси
інформацію за місцем у ж названого там
основні склади та комп'ютерів так і але
електроні прибудована школа нас туди але
там ми дізнаємось мені з та тішить для
харчування тексті МВД і мід текстовий
інформації за 1000 довідки дітям важливі
буде ще може допомагаючи ви
простакуватий комп'ютер самої для курей і
знову ви курас танець їх ми вистоємо про
сучасна на роботі з картами
темі інформація про щупа не дари образа
говорила тортів тут реалізований
принцип у тому числі міжпредметна
інформації так да але дар мови нарахування
проходячи в 4вд м.а.с. про pdf такі
програми вання команди і ви фанати r&b
загоєння слова алгоритми
за пропозиції ми також просто відняв було
туди на тему текстова інформація про
третьому класі я не буду зрозуміти і
сената моє кімчі нам зміни зміни
терміни для того, щоб на вигляд побачив і
вику ви москви владі кочіткової школи
і буде кому ви папку загальна вираз
було вілли крапельки з коментарів
процесі у нас на предмет інформатика в
школі, а предмети історії про комп'ютерну
техніки
все було чесно помив катом ще
інформатика з робота за інформацію вона
історія як погляду на комп'ютер 3024 руки
в тому й тягин і вже закладу ні в чому на
програму вона вже виставлено на і
двері і на ній у надзвичайно паза ти
поза видом борошна протягну люди просто не
може повірити ще для таких виродків
термін поставлені зад з нині в такі
жорсткі ви багато людей люди смоли разом
на стиль кису ті відьміни